do attractive parents have more girls
uh and i guess i first read that more
broadly not as attractive but sort of
you know higher quality whatever that
means which would be a direct allusion
to the trevor's willard hypothesis which
was published in mid-70s probably which
suggests that
because put humans aside for the moment
because the
variability in reproductive success is
so much greater for males than it is for
females that is
um that females uh no matter how many
matings they get no matter what the
social system is tend to have
you know roughly two surviving offspring
that make it into the next generation
that then go on to reproduce themselves
that is they exactly replace themselves
in a in a stable population situation
whereas males have a highly variable
number of offspring and
how many they have varies greatly by the
number of reproductive opportunities
that they find for themselves or make
for themselves
so the prediction of the trooper's
wheeler hypothesis is that
the higher the quality offspring you can
produce the more likely you are to
produce
males because because males have such a
greater variability
in reproductive success you want to make
sure that your highest quality offspring
are more likely to be males with a
higher variability with a higher chance
of getting
more offspring themselves this is a
purely genetic argument
and obviously with humans where we tend
towards monogamy
and where female beauty in particular is
a
a big predictor of basically wealth
acquisition and also reproductive
success
this may this may at least mitigate the
effects of trevor's willard or even flip
it on its head
wait wait wait i was with you until that
last okay well i didn't say it well i
said
it may no no i i thought where you were
headed
um is that uh all else being equal a
very important phrase here
all else being equal um prettier women
should tend to have
male offspring because of the downstream
consequences of beauty
in mating and dating so not only
of male beauty no i thought we were
talking about female beauty right well
but
so you just said women beautiful women
should be more likely to have male
offspring
but if it's because of the role of
female beauty and mating and dating why
wouldn't
why wouldn't you expect a flip of
trevor's willard because
uh beautiful women would be more likely
therefore to
uh to themselves again attract more
high quality mates yeah higher quality
mates they would they would they would
tend to marry up and therefore
the chances that a male offspring that
they produce would be successful would
be
higher than if we take their
beauty out of the equation and we figure
out where they would have made it in the
hierarchy
based on other characteristics so if a
woman can marry up it should
increase the chances of her producing
male offspring because the offspring
will be better placed
to reproduce themselves and she's less
likely to produce dead ends
so how is that different how how does
the human situation that's just a
classic
trevor's willard argument that doesn't
change in any way
like so the fact of female beauty or not
actually doesn't even belong in that
conversation it's changed the argument
not at all
well right i think this is standard
trevor's world i don't know i i have yet
to see
why why the logic would reverse here um
it's just that beauty plays a certain
role in human mating and dating
and i mean because there's choice
because because both men and women
choose
right um to to a greater degree than uh
really is found in just about any other
mammals and there are a number of
monogamous species of birds but
um in in a mostly monogamous species
as as we are where you have choice on on
both parts and where
female beauty and specifically
indicators of youth and fertility
are highly prized across culture you
might expect a woman with
those characteristics um to exactly want
to replicate them in her daughters
because
she will want daughters who will be
similarly chosen
um by also highly ranked men because
female beauty doesn't necessarily
convert into the indicators of says for
men right like
you know if success for men is often
about wealth and um
and you know later in life success now i
get your argument
okay but i still think it goes the other
way
precisely because of the thing that sits
at the bottom of the trevor's willard
analysis which is that the variance for
women is lower and therefore
so first of all no matter no matter what
else is true about humans still
there's only so many kids a woman can
have in her lifetime and the number of
kids a man can have in his lifetime is
basically unbounded but don't try
right but so anyway just just to
complete it
if woman so first of all there is there
are several layers
playing into this discussion one is that
a beautiful woman is likely genetically
well endowed
and has had access to resources that or
her mother did that would result in you
know this is one of the things that bob
trivers has looked
deeply into um is the fluctuating
right basically we find symmetry uh
pleasing
and so a woman who is beautiful likely
is genetically well endowed and has also
had a developmental environment that was
hospitable
um which uh you know some of this is
heritable and some of it isn't
right but a beautiful woman is probably
if those characteristics are right
if she's especially symmetrical for one
thing she may also it's not that her
it's not that she is capable of
producing female beauty she is likely
capable of producing
beautiful well put together offspring of
either sex
she is also capable of commanding more
in the mating and dating market
and therefore she you know let's just
say that
male quality physical quality doesn't
even matter
right certain things like a higher
position in society
she can marry somebody who has a higher
position in society which increases the
chances that her offspring
will be able to find mates although
until until very recently until
post-industrial cultures
often higher position in society for
males needed to be vetted with
uh tests of physical prowess early on
yep i still i still think that all these
things point in the same direction
that which is that whatever it is the
female beauty is a proxy for whether it
is
you know mediated through males who are
choosing or whether it is mediated
through nature and her ability to
produce
offspring that are well structured in
both cases the unsettling and
uncomfortable conclusion of trevor's
willard
is if you have some reason to know that
your offspring are liable to be
more capable than average rather than
less capable than average
then you should tend to produce males
and in a more cert uncertain context you
should tend to produce
females and that female beauty if it
does anything it tells you
she should be more likely to produce
males because she's more likely to
produce
males that are well positioned and
well-structured fair enough
okay we could we could of course go on
for hours as we probably will later yes
we could
off the camera um and i will say and
maybe correct me i
you know i didn't didn't see this
question coming but i think
i don't know that trevor willard has
been investigated with regard to
mechanism in humans or even investigated
necessarily in humans at all but it has
been looked at in some
species of mammals where the mechanism
actually appears to possibly be
choice of the egg now by the egg of
particular sperm because
mammals have chromosomal sex
determination i believe and
you know it's possible i'm just making
this up but i think i think i remember
one or two papers suggesting that
basically the egg
nose and obviously none of this is
conscious we're using this evolutionary
shorthand but
the egg can tell x sperm versus y sperm
in a mammal and b z versus w sperm in a
bird
no actually in birds it's going to be
totally different because they've got
this different sex as heterogametic in
birds um but
in mammals x-sperm vs y-sperm the egg
can tell and therefore the egg can make
choices based on the sex of the sperm
that is approaching them
and appears to do so i will try to find
that
find that to make sure that i'm not
making it up for the next time